[Musik]
erster arbeitstag im weißen haus
us-präsident beiden feiert seine
amtseinführung und fängt sofort an die
politik des vorgängers wird gängig zu
machen angst vor corona mutation ein eu
gipfel berät über gegenmaßnahmen
bundeskanzlerin merkel sieht
grenzkontrollen als letztes mittel und
urlaubsinsel am abgrund weil keine
touristen mehr kommen rutschen immer
mehr menschen auf mallorca in die armut
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber einen guten abend in
allen heute um 7 danke dass sie bei uns
sind sports nachher in dieser sendung
mit kristin otto und handball und
biathlon guten amerikas 46 präsident
möchte seinen bürgern zeigen ich mache
mich sofort an die arbeit und das sollen
richtungsweisende entscheidungen seien
gleich zu beginn weg vom kurs seines
vorgängers und ein deutlich
entschiedener kampf gegen korona eine
neue ära in washington us präsident joe
biden unterschreibt direkt nach
amtsantritt insgesamt 17 dekrete und
verordnungen unter anderem die rückkehr
der usa ins pariser klimaabkommen wieder
mitarbeit bei der
weltgesundheitsorganisation und stopp
von trumps grenzmauer zu mexiko aus
washington berichtet elm at wissen
das fest wird weggeräumt schluss mit
feiern und mit der furcht vor unruhen
washington bald wieder im normalbetrieb
die koffer mit den atomkurs sind auch
schon da amerikas sicherheit und ein
stück bei die der welt liegt jetzt in
seiner hand und mit der unterschrieb joe
biden gleich einen stapel von dekreten
eine masken pflicht in allen
bundesgebäuden schutz für die kinder
illegaler einwanderer den wiedereintritt
in die weltgesundheitsorganisation und
ins pariser klimaschutzabkommen ach ja
und ein schreiben hat er gefunden von
donald trump der präsident hat mir einen
sehr günstigen brief geschrieben weil er
privat ist rede ich nicht drüber bis ich
mit ihm gesprochen habe aber er war
mutig
vizepräsident in harrys schuhe die neuen
senatoren rein jetzt haben die
demokraten auch eine mehrheit im senat
und der bestätigte gleich die neue
geheimdienstkoordinator in adelaide auch
im presseraum des weißen hauses ein
neuanfang denn sie machte den
journalisten ja dem ganzen land ein
kühnes versprechen es wird tage geben an
denen wir eine konträre sicht der dinge
haben aber trotzdem ein gemeinsames ziel
die amerikaner akkurat zu informieren
ehrlichkeit respekt
gesprächsbereitschaft so die
parteiübergreifende botschaft von drei
ehemaligen präsidenten das brauche die
nation
wenn amerikaner ihre nachbarn lieben wie
sie selbst geliebt werden wollen dann
würde die spaltung der gesellschaft
enden
gute wünsche für eine präsidentschaft in
der die neuen zeigen müssen ob sie das
land herausführen können aus den krisen
dieser zeit tolle bilder und dann gucken
wir uns mal ganz konkret auf die
situation mit ines trams live in
washington
wie schnell werden denn die amerikaner
merken dass es da eine neue politik gibt
im weißen haus
ich denke corona bietet dem neuen
präsidenten ja nur ein kleines
zeitfenster zu handeln entsprechend
werden so denke ich die amerikaner
schnell realisieren dass beiden ansatz
die pandemie einzudämmen ein anderer ist
es wird ein ansatz sein der basieren
wird auf wissenschaftlichen daten nicht
auf parteipolitik und so zynisch es
klingen mag corona bietet beiden ja eine
große chance gelingt es ihm mit
wirtschaftshilfen und mit groß
angelegten im pfund testprogrammen das
leid der menschen ganz konkret zu
lindern dann könnte er zügig das
vertrauen der menschen in die politik
generell zurückgewinnen und vertrauen in
ihn als präsidenten als neuen
präsidenten gewinnen freundlich winkende
menschen sehen wir bei ihnen im
hintergrund aber was ist mit beiden
gegnern verdient haben wir jetzt in den
letzten tagen wenig gehört ist das eine
trügerische ruhe
das könnte so seine beiden präsentiert
sich als mann der einheit als versöhner
doch nur mit rhetorik wird er die trump
anhänger nicht mitnehmen können denke
ich es steht daher vor zweierlei
herausforderungen zum einen glauben nach
wie vor viele viele republikanische
wähler das beiden nicht der rechtmäßig
gewählte präsident ist und zum anderen
sind die trump anhänger im engeren sinne
für die etablierte washingtoner politik
oftmals nur noch schwer zu erreichen zu
weit haben sie sich bereits von der
politik und der realität entfernt ein
richtiger ansatz könnte sicherlich seien
ganz konkret zu versuchen das leid die
sorgen die nöte der tramp anhänger zu
lindern und ich denke das könnte ein
ansatz sein
die radikale umkehr von chance politik
stößt diese menschen er vor den kopf
in vielen dank nach washington ein
neuanfang in amerika der start der
regierung beiden in der zdf- heute- app
gibt es unter anderem eine übersicht
über die minister und berater des neuen
us präsidenten
unser nächstes großes thema heute abend
die korona lage in deutschland und da
geht der trend bei den neuinfektionen
deutlich nach unten
das robert koch institut meldet eine 7
tage incidents von 119
das ist der niedrigste wert seit dem
ersten november binnen eines tages
wurden 20.000 398 neuinfektionen
gemeldet und nach wie vor hoch ist
allerdings die zahl der menschen die in
verbindung mit cupid 19 starben 1013
menschen
die bundeskanzlerin war heute für den
verlängerten shutdown versuchte aber
auch hoffnung zu machen und nannte ein
konkretes datum beim impfen wenn alles
wie zugesagt klappe werde jeder bürger
bis ende des sommers ein impfangebot
bekommen bis zum 21 september mehr von
britta spiekermann
es ist durchaus selten angela merkel
stellt sich den fragen der hauptstadt
journalisten in der
bundespressekonferenz und es ist erst
recht ungewöhnlich hatte sie doch erst
am dienstag rede und antwort gestanden
nachdem bund länder treffen glaubt
merkel sich erneut rechtfertigen zu
müssen
diese pandemie wird mit recht von allen
als eine zumutung empfunden
und wenn zumutungen sehr lange dauern
dann werden sie immer schwerer auch zu
bewältigen
das gilt jeden so es treibt sie offenbar
um schulen und kitas bleiben weiter
geschlossen bis mitte februar wohl
mindestens die wiederöffnung habe aber
priorität eine verlässliche perspektive
aus ihrer sicht kaum möglich ein spruch
sagt die opposition weil wir die
zuversicht bauen
vom licht am ende des tunnels zu reden
reicht nicht dieses licht muss heller
werden wir brauchen jetzt endlich eine
gemeinsame perspektive einen gemeinsamen
stufenplan
die menschen brauchen eine aussicht sie
brauchen eine klare perspektive wir in
der politik übrigens auch perspektive
impfen jedem solle bis zum ende des
sommers ein impfangebot gemacht werden
sagt merkel
eine garantie
gebe es aber nicht nächstes kapitel
gleich heute abend europäischer rat per
video-konferenz themen mutation und
grenzen ziel eine gemeinsame strategie
noch gilt zusammenarbeit nicht
abschottung
ich kann darstellen dass deutschland
einen kooperativen ansatz sucht und das
für uns auch die grenzkontrollen
flächendeckend die ultima ratio wären
und dass wir viel tun werden um zu
versuchen das zu verhindern
kanzlerin merkel hat von zumutungen
gesprochen die an den nerven aller
zerrten
es ist die angst die lage könnte auch in
deutschland außer kontrolle geraten
statt down bis mitte februar so viel ist
sicher
die weitere perspektive unsicher ganz
gut gesehen die bundeskanzlerin also
setzt auf gemeinsamkeit in der eu um die
korona krise in den griff zu bekommen
tatsächlich sieht das in der pandemie
häufig anders aus die eu-staaten beraten
im moment darüber insbesondere wie man
die rasche ausbreitung auch der
mutationen verhindern und trotzdem die
grenzen offen lassen kann zumindest
diskutiert werden ein eu-weit gültiger
impfpass als erlaubnis für freies reisen
und wege damit die hersteller mehr
impfstoff produzieren können
anne gellinek beobachtet für uns das
ganze in brüssel eine das
schreckgespenst grenzen dicht das steht
ja im raum worauf läuft es denn jetzt
hinaus für europa die staats und
regierungschefs machen sich tatsächlich
erhebliche sorgen über diese
virusvarianten und wollen versuchen in
dieser videokonferenz- zu beraten wie
man denn entschlossen und gemeinsam
diese mutationen bekämpfen könnte dabei
kann man die diskussion über
grenzschließungen die er von den
deutschen ins spiel gebracht wurden
durchaus als druckmittel als drohung
betrachten sich doch jetzt bitte
möglichst schnell europäisch zu einigen
die idee der deutschen ist dass man bei
den infektionszahlen gemeinsame
schwellenwerte festlegt die dann auch
gemeinsame maßnahmen nach sich zögen
also zum beispiel bei neuinfektionen im
deutsch-tschechischen grenzbereich dass
man dann auf beiden seiten der grenzen
geschäfte schließt oder quarantäne
regeln
führt auch von testzentren an den
grenzen ist die rede um schlagbäume
offen zu halten
sicher ist dass auch das thema der
erhöhten impfstoffproduktion heute abend
bei der video konferenz eine rolle
spielen wird und die frage warum man
eigentlich noch so wenig über die
mutationen weiß die mitgliedstaaten
testen zu wenig und stochern in dieser
frage noch ziemlich im nebel
wir sind gespannt auf die ergebnisse an
vielen dank nach brüssel
warum die sorge vor der virus mutation
so groß ist das zeigt der blick nach
großbritannien dort breitet sich die
ansteckende variante von corona weiter
aus trotz lockdown und obwohl die
regierung die impfungen im eiltempo
voran treibt sinken die infektionszahlen
nicht das zeigt eine aktuelle studie
besonders besorgniserregend die zahl der
toten gestern waren es 1800 20 menschen
ein tageshöchstwert und die
intensivstation sind am anschlag von
dort berichtet andreas stamm eine frau
mitte 20 keine sauerstoffzufuhr mehr in
bauchlage bringen ihre letzte chance
intensivmediziner am limit viele hier
freiwillige aus anderen bereichen des
londoner royal free hospital
es gelingt ihnen die patientin erst mal
stabil
sie ist jung hat familie wir kämpfen
hier um etwas so wertvolles das macht
mir unheimlich angst 12 von 15
stockwerken des krankenhauses sind mit
corona patienten belegt dr banker sucht
dringend ein bett für eine neuaufnahme
corona und schlaganfall notiert er
sie haben die zahl der intensivbetten
verdreifacht es findet sich 1 es war
einer stunde lag darin hanna freeborn
mutter großmutter sie wurde 64
ich wünsche dass niemandem hier müsst
aufpassen es ist schrecklich und real
eine warnung auch vor der in südengland
entdeckten corona mutation deutlich
ansteckender und eine studie mit 143.000
personen in england lässt befürchten
selbst der strikte lockdown seit anfang
januar konnte die neue infektionszahlen
bislang nicht entscheidend verringern
die regeln des londons beachten zu hause
bleiben dass noch mehr zu beherzigen ist
entscheidend
aber vor uns liegen auf jeden fall harte
wochen die patienten flut dürfte nicht
abreißen die todeszahlen hoch bleiben
folgen einer corona mutation die außer
kontrolle geraten ist
wie sehr auch die wirtschaft und ganze
existenzen unter corona leiden zeigt
sich gerade in den regionen die vom
tourismus leben sowie mallorca sonst
partyinsel und sonniges
lieblingsreiseziel vieler deutscher
urlauber
der tourismus macht dort mehr als ein
drittel der wirtschaftsleistung aus und
jetzt sieht es so aus shutdown
ausgangssperre kaum gäste und 80 prozent
- im letzten jahr verglichen mit dem
davor immer mehr menschen aus mallorca
rutschen in die armut eine arbeit
berichtet man nennt sie die neuen armen
die kellner zimmermädchen all jene die
vom tourismus lebten und nun geduldig an
einer der vielen essensausgaben in palma
warten dass sie mal auf spenden
angewiesen ist hätte kamen nie gedacht
es gibt keine arbeit nirgends nicht
einmal als putzfrau bei jemandem zu
hause oder in den büros nirgendwo
gottseidank bekomme ich hier etwas
unterstützung bars restaurants große
geschäfte geschlossen beide lockerungen
schließt die regionalregierung aus das
trifft auch jene die ihre läden zu
öffnen dürfen doch kaum noch kunden
haben
wenn die leute nicht mehr arbeiten gehen
sie auch nicht mehr zum friseur
wenn es keine fest keine hochzeiten gibt
gibt es für die leute keinen grund sich
zurechtzumachen und genauso wenig wenn
du nicht weißt ob du deinen job behältst
denn 400 euro sozialhilfe reichen kaum
zum leben die hohen mieten bleiben
oft sind ganze familien vom tourismus
abhängig nun kommen sie nur noch dank
der unterstützung von
hilfsorganisationen über die runden
es ist hart einem kind zu sagen nein
dafür haben wir kein geld und darf
ja auch nicht und so bleibt es wohl das
ganze jahr so wird die korona krise mehr
und mehr zur sozialen krise auf mallorca
der sonst so beliebten urlaubsinsel den
üblichen saisonstart zu ostern hat hier
manch einer schon abgeschrieben
ein anderes thema jetzt keine besseren
nachrichten im irak heute nach längerer
ruhiger phase wieder ein verheerender
anschlag in der hauptstadt bagdad
starben dabei mindestens 32 menschen
über 100 menschen wurden verletzt
zwei selbstmordattentäter hatten sich
auf einem belebten markt im stadtzentrum
in die luft gesprengt
nach einer verfolgungsjagd mit
sicherheitskräften sagte ein
armeesprecher
noch hat sich niemand zu der tat bekannt
zurück nach deutschland der tödliche
anschlag auch walter lübke ist jetzt
rund anderthalb jahre her
fest steht stephanie ist der täter auch
das motiv ist klar fremdenfeindlichkeit
der kasseler regierungspräsident hatte
sich aus seiner sicht zu sehr für
flüchtlinge eingesetzt
nächste woche soll das urteil gesprochen
werden die entscheidende frage war es
mord oder totschlag heute das plädoyer
des verteidigers der sich den medien
gegenüber nicht äußern wollte sondern
china als weiterhin sehr gefährlich
hatte der gutachter den hauptangeklagten
stefan ernst eingeschätzt
auch deswegen fordert die
bundesanwaltschaft für ihn nicht nur
lebenslange haft sondern auch
anschließende sicherungsverwahrung
doch der anwalt von ernst plädierte
heute nur auf totschlag
es fehlten mordmerkmale wie niedrige
beweggründe
die bundesanwaltschaft ist anderer
meinung unter anderem und geht es um ein
rassistisches motiv und das ist dass es
auch anerkannt niedrig im sinne des
mordes und führt damit meiner
überzeugung auch zwingend zu einer
verurteilung wegen mordes
auch das mordmerkmal der heimtücke
stellt der anwalt von stefan ernst in
frage hintergrund ist die letzte tat
version von ernst in der markus h der
mittäterschaft beschuldigt ernst hatte
bestanden weiter luft auf seiner
terrasse erschossen zu haben
sagte aber auch aus dass markus haar in
der tat nach dabei war
beide hätten kurz mit dem politiker
gesprochen bevor stefan ernst weiter
lücke erschossen habe würde die
tatversion stimmen was beide zuvor mit
weiterer lübke geredet hätten dann würde
das mordmerkmal der heimtücke
möglicherweise fehlen
die bundesanwaltschaft geht aber ohnehin
nicht davon aus dass markus damit am
tatort war
sie glaubt davon ernst war alleintäter
der anwalt von stefan ernst appellierte
an den richter das umfassende geständnis
das ernst gemacht hatte beim urteil zu
berücksichtigen die familie von walter
lübke sieht das anders
das ändert nichts daran dass die familie
ist für richtig halten würde wenn auch
die besondere schwere der schuld mit
anschließender sicherungsverwahrung
festgestellt wird das urteil über den
mutmaßlichen mörder von walter lübke
soll heute in einer woche fallen
das sturmtief koran hat vor allem im
nordwesten von deutschland schwere
schäden angerichtet den nordrhein
westfalen und niedersachsen wie hier in
oldenburg wurden bäume entwurzelt
auf der autobahn 27 kippte ein lastwagen
um feuerwehr und polizei rückten zu
zahlreichen einsätzen aus woran
erreichte windgeschwindigkeiten von über
100 kilometern in der stunde und mehr
zum wetter wie es wird gleich in der
sendung erst haben wir auch den sport
natürlich christin handballer bitte
genau und spannender abend steht bevor
in gut einer stunde live hier bei uns im
zdf anwurf zum ersten hauptrundenspiel
der deutschen nationalmannschaft bei der
weltmeisterschaft ausgerechnet gegen die
sehr sehr starken spanier also ein
echter härtetest bei dem alles passen
muss spanien ein dicker brocken
der aktuelle europameister hat die
erfahrenste mannschaft des turniers eine
chance hat das junge deutsche team nur
wenn die fehler aus dem ungarn spiel
abgestellt werden
wir müssen das zentrum viel kompakter
halten am besten von der ersten sekunde
haben mit dieser aggressivität spielen
die wir mitte des spiels gegen ungarn
hatten im neuen hotel am ostrand kairos
gelegenheit zu auf lockerem training und
intensivem studium des neuen gegners
verhaltener optimismus
ich kann mich an einige meisterschaften
erinnern wo deutschland mal ein
wichtiges spiel verloren und trotzdem
was erreicht hat
eine weitere niederlage und die chancen
aufs viertelfinale wären nur noch
minimal
tja der erfolgsdruck ist also hoch lena
kesting in ägypten worauf kommt es denn
gegen die spanier noch an
für die deutsche mannschaft kommt hier
beim handball klassiker auf zwei
entscheidende dinge an das eine ist der
torhüter der stark halten muss gegen
diese erfahrenen spanier noch ist nicht
klar wie in der bundestrainer ins tor
stellt vermutlich aber andreas wolf der
zweite ist das tempo die deutschen
müssen es schaffen nach einem ballgewinn
schnell umzuschalten und die spanier im
idealfall zu überrumpeln denn nur mit
einem sieg heute war die dhb auswahl die
chance mit eigener kraft ins
wm-viertelfinale hier in ägypten
einzuziehen
ja und ob das klappt da können sie
natürlich verfolgen von 20 uhr fünfte
dann hier live lena vielen dank für die
einstimmung und noch zum biathlon mit
einem beachtlichen fünften platz für
janina hettich über 15 kilometer im
italienischen antholz
erst durch einen fehler im letzten jahr
20 schüsse und der straff minute
verpasste sie einen podiumsplatz
dennoch ist es ihr bestes weltcup
resultat
der tagessieg geht erstmalig an dieser
theresa hauser aus österreich und morgen
dann die männer auch live hier bei uns
kristin vielen dank herr sturm und
orkanen uns heute durchgerüttelt die
bilder haben wir gerade gesehen wie
windig und wenig winterlich es
weitergeht sagt uns gleich katja
horneffer ich empfehle ihnen das heute
journal mit der kollegin marietta slomka
in der handball halbzeit gegen 21 uhr 10
so ungefähr
wir sind morgen wieder für sie da
wünschen ihnen aber erstmal einen sehr
angenehm
[Musik]
er nahm meine damen und herren orkantief
koran hat uns ja heute ordentlich
durchgerüttelt inzwischen liegt es über
der nordsee zieht aber einige tiefs
hinter sich hier das eine zieht hier
über dänemark bis morgen abend weiter
nach südschweden das andere startet über
der biskaya und peilt die westalpen an
heute nachtreten das also im westen und
im norden kräftig zum teil mit starken
bis stürmischen süd wird
im osten ist es dagegen zum teil auch
klar und fällt der regen auf gefrorenem
boden kann es natürlich glatt werden
meist aber bleibt die nacht zu mild für
glätte bei tiefsttemperaturen zwischen
10 und 4 grad und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen in nordfriesland am
niederrhein und an der donau bei 6 grad
am mildesten wird sich am oberrhein mit
14 grad und ähnliche in der nacht sie
noch morgen über tag die regenwolken von
südwest nach nordost über uns hinweg
nordwestlich davon zeigt sich spätestens
am nachmittag bei südwestwind auch mal
die sonne und im südosten zeigt sie sich
morgen auch und das liegt am 5 deswegen
bleibt es an den alpen also recht sonnig
aber spätestens in der nacht zu samstag
wird der föhn zusammenbrechen
die winde drehen auf nördliche
richtungen und die neue woche startet
winterlich kalt bei minus zwei bis plus
vier grad
schönen abend noch